-Welcome back, everybody.
We are hanging out with
Tiffany Haddish!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her new show, "The Afterparty,"
premieres this Friday
on Apple TV+.
The show takes place on the
night of a high school reunion.
Have you ever gone back to
your high school reunion?
Or gone to one?
-Oh, definitely.
I've been to
my high school reunions.
This is how you know
you made it, Jimmy.
They schedule the reunions
around my schedule.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They call, they like, "Tiffany,
you coming to the reunion?"
I'm like,
"When is it? When is it?"
They're like,
"When are you available?"
I'm like,
"She made it, she ready.
Okay, so here are my days."
We even had one of the reunions,
our 15th reunion,
the year 15, we had it
at the comedy club.
I was like, "Ooh, that night,
I got to do a show."
They was like,
"Where's the show at?"
I was like,
"Flappers in Burbank."
They were like, "That's where
the reunion will be."
-No way.
So you got to see everyone
from your high school
in the crowd?
-Yeah, every -- It was everybody
from high school.
So it kind of turned into
like an impromptu roast.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-So, it was good.
-I've done that too.
I remember doing stand-up,
and my principal came to see me
do stand-up.
And he was like, "Hi, you
remember me?" or whatever.
I go, "Oh, my -- Yeah."
And then I was like,
"I don't have any material
to make fun of you, but I will."
-You didn't make fun of
the principal?
-I couldn't -- I couldn't --
I didn't have material
about the pr-- He liked me.
He was a great -- I was, like,
the kid in school that I --
If I would get in trouble
and then the principal would be
like, "What did you do?"
I'd go, "I made a joke
or something."
He was like, "Ah, do you want to
go to detention?"
I go, "Sure."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we just had a deal.
We had an understanding.
I was hanging out in the office.
And I would go to
the principal's office
and just say, "What's up?"
and hang out.
-My principal at --
Let me tell you something.
When I was in school,
I used to get sent
to the principal's office often.
But see, I was a businesswoman.
[ Laughter ]
And one day I got sent to
the principal's office
because I decided to quit
being the mascot,
and they needed me
back on the field
'cause the numbers
was dropping low.
The morale was dropping low.
And so we had negotiated a deal,
because I would throw out candy
and I would get the candy
from my home girl
who worked at the 99-cent store,
right?
And she owed me some favors
'cause I would babysit
or whatever.
But anyways, I told him, "Look,
I can't get back on the field
unless I get paid,
because I need a boyfriend.
I don't have no boyfriend.
I need to get my hair done
and my nails done
so I can get a boyfriend."
And then he was like, "I can't
pay you to be a mascot."
I said, "Well, look, we got to
figure out something."
So by the time we finished
negotiating, you know,
I was making about, you know,
$50 to $100 a game.
-See, that's what I'm
talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You were the mascot of the team?
What was the mascot?
What was it?
-Oh, it was a conquistador.
I was a Spanish soldier,
darling, full garb.
-Wow, wow, the conquistador.
And you had to wear a full
costume and everything?
-Yeah, I wore the full costume,
but I did not wear the head
'cause the head --
it was an old costume.
You know, the school was built
in the '50s.
I graduated in the 1990s --
1900s.
Anyways.
[ Laughter ]
The head was not a good smell,
so I didn't wear the head.
It was full costume but my head.
And I was the only talking
mascot in the Valley.
I'd be like, "El Ca-- What?!
And everyone would be like,
"Mino!"
I went to El Camino Real.
"El Ca-- What?"
"Mino!"
"Who know? We know! Baby!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's how you do it.
I want to talk about
"The Afterparty."
It's on this Friday, Apple TV+.
How do we set it up
for everybody? What do we say?
-So, if you love to play
the game "Clue," right?
Remember the game "Clue"?
-Of course, love it.
-So it's a mystery show,
and every episode is a different
genre of TV and movie.
So the first episode
is the rom-com.
And another episode is
a thriller or action.
And, you know, it's just fun.
It's just a really fun show.
Show them the clip.
-Yeah, here we go.
I want to show the clip.
Here's Tiffany Haddish
in "The Afterparty."
Take a look at this.
-Culp, good.
I need somebody to --
-Captain called me.
-Really?
I didn't know you guys
were friends.
-Oh, we're not.
He just wanted me to hear it
directly from him
that this is not our case.
He only wanted us to collect
witness statements
until Jermaine got here.
-Okay, so that is basically what
he said to me as well,
but look, I can crack
this thing, okay?
-You lied to me.
-You're being dramatic.
-Do not call me dramatic!
-It's cool. Look, if I don't
solve this case,
I promise you
I will take the rap.
I will not let any harm
come to you.
But this ringer guy that's
coming, I know him.
And he will...this up.
Now, I'm not asking you
to help me.
I'm just asking you to not
not help me, okay?
-Yeah, "I'm just asking you
to not, not."
Tiffany Haddish, everybody.
-"Not, not help me."
-"The Afterparty" premieres
Friday on Apple TV+.
We love you, bud.